incarnate was directed by Brad Payton
the man behind san andreas journey to
the mysterious island and cats and dogs
the revenge of Kitty galore and this
film isn't good all jokes aside this
movie stars Aaron Eckhart as a
demonologist of sorts but he doesn't
really believe in the supernatural
he kind of accepts that parasitic
entities exist but he doesn't like to
refer to them as demons he doesn't refer
to the devil as being a thing he just
believes that strange entities can take
over somebody and he has this machinery
that allows him to dive into the
person's mind via some wires and
computers then he meets that person in
their subconscious and forces them out
of some sort of dreamlike scenario that
allows them to be free from whatever's
possessing them he's also haunted by a
woman who seems to invade all of these
dreamlike scenarios named Maggie that he
is constantly trying to find so yeah
this is an inception combined with the
Exorcist at all it's definitely an
original film that was in no way
inspired by those far better movies I
like Aaron Eckhart a lot I think he's an
actor that when he gets the right role
he can really shine like in the Dark
Knight or Erin Brockovich but then he
can be in films like I Frankenstein or
incarnate and he's easily the best part
of this movie he's giving a far better
performance and this movie deserves even
though he's kind of doing his aaron
eckhart gravelly Batman voice and it
doesn't always work my major issue with
this movie is how terrible its
screenplay is how messy the direction is
and how the entire film just feels like
a gigantic deleted scene almost all this
movie just feels like it was reshot at
the last second like they had a scene
that worked and they decided to go in a
different direction and that's the
direction they took and this is the
movie we now have it just feels like a
big blu-ray special feature that really
should not be a theatrical film there's
so much exposition in the dialogue that
is meant to set up this world with so
many rules that we're supposed to
and adhere to as we watch the film but
it's really just characters saying
things like this boy who's been
possessed has three days until he dies
and you're like why does he have three
days why is it three days who said it
had to be three days and how do you have
this computer machine lets you go in his
mind with some wires there's a scene
where Eckhart visits an old friend who's
currently locking up someone who is
possessed purely for the purpose of
studying him and it felt like that scene
was just there so they could set up some
sort of scary jump-scare scene later
where Aaron Eckhart has to go back and
visit this friend and that guy's escaped
you're like oh and that scene leads
to nothing I mean really this entire
film is just a bunch of scenes that lead
to really nothing there's so much that
they could have had with a story like
this because it does take a decidedly
original turn from your normal exorcism
movie even though you can really see the
comparisons with inception and sometimes
it's very blatant it's enjoyable that
they tried to do something slightly
different but the film never really
takes advantage of the fact that it is a
little different and it just goes in the
conventional Hollywood route every
chance it gets with tons of stupid
pointless jump scares a lot of really
horribly clumsily directed action
sequences and a terribly composed final
shot with awful visual effects that just
it made me laugh to be honest it was so
bad so Aaron Eckhart is probably the
best part of this movie Carice van
Houten if that's how you pronounce her
name was also pretty good the young kid
who was also another possessed kid
earlier this year in the movie The
Darkness with Kevin Bacon
yeah that splat he does the same
thing here again he's another possessed
kid in a terrible shitty movie so I
really don't know what's going on there
this is a movie that should have came
out around Halloween that has been
thrown into one weekend of December to
just be like here please forget about
this right now because we have other
things to do I'm gonna give incarnate a
d-plus it's a quick easy watch you can
admire Aaron Eckhart in this film for
his work and how much he's trying but
this is a movie where they actually have
computers with real graphics that
measure the demon activity going on in
somebody like a big green orb that like
goes like this as
measures the amount of but of course
it's not a demon it's a parasitic entity
so in case you're wondering I am a
little sick right now I'm getting over a
cold hopefully that doesn't last too
long so I got some more reviews coming
for you very soon from films I saw while
I was in LA I saw the anime film your
name I also saw a nocturnal animals
those are going to come in very soon
guys thank you very much for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get steppen eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you